hello everyone I'm Kevin Davis publisher
of senior and welcome to the precision
medicine virtual event hosted by my lab
roots are next week here is dr. Musa
malanga from South Africa and after a
few housekeeping notes I will introduce
Musa we're very excited to have him
presenting we are pre recording this
particular web presentation for
scheduling reason so there won't be a
live Q&A but I will come back at the end
of this presentation to to ask a few few
quick questions the precision medicine
virtual event is hosted by lab roots the
leading scientific social networking
websites and provider of virtual events
and webinars senior is proud and pleased
to be the official media partner and
we've also played a role in crafting the
program for the entire day today if you
do important announcements before we get
started you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking the on the screen icon in
the lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have a technical problem
such during this during this webcast you
can kick the support button is on the
top right of your presentation window
was submit your problem through the
green Q&A box and somebody will try to
assist you as soon as you can this is an
educational webinar and we're offering
free continuing education credits after
the webinar is over invite you to click
on the cee button located in the bottom
left-hand corner of the web page and
follow the process for obtaining your
credits and so forth to introduce our
speaker dr. Luther malanga he is a
research professor in the division of
chemical systems and synthetic biology
the University of Cape Town in the
factory of Health Sciences in South
Africa he's an american-born cell
biologist I holds a PhD in cell biology
molecular genetics he trained to the
University School of Medicine and also
Rockefeller University the lab of David
Howe he later moved to the
due to pastor in Paris working in the
laboratory of nuclear cell biology on
issues such as RNA transport and
tracking of RNA in living cells Musa
moved his lab to South Africa in 2008
where they joined the council of
scientific industrial research as with
such leader of synthetic biology he
heads the laboratory for gene expression
and biophysics and holds a joint
appointment at the Institute of
Molecular Medicine in lisbon in portugal
his lab works on gene regulation
host-pathogen interactions civil
molecule imaging and gene expression and
the development of high-throughput body
techniques for swooning in both basic
and clinical biology and title of his
talk today is bringing precision
medicine in oncology to South Africa and
so is a great pleasure to introduce and
welcome Moussa malanga sir malanga thank
you for that newbie kind introduction
Kevin and it's a pleasure to participate
in this international webinar on
precision medicine we are just beginning
our precision medicine efforts here in
South Africa and so this talk is really
give you an overview of the state of
ecology in Africa and in South Africa
and how some of the approaches that we
would like to bring to the oncology
clinical space really try to leapfrog to
the state of the art that exists in
other parts of the world today so I'm
this initiative to give a bit of
background is called the biomedical
translational research initiative and
it's a partnership between the council
or scientific and industrial research of
South Africa as well as the University
of Cape Tom Faculty of Health Sciences
over school of medicine now a few facts
about cancer worldwide which I'm sure
don't need to be really over highlighted
to this audience but it's really among
the leading causes of morbidity and
mortality worldwide with over 14 million
new cases every year and at least 8.2
million cancer related deaths it's a
Nixon announcing the war on cancer back
in 1972 and and at least by these
numbers were not winning that war um the
number of new cases is expected to rise
by about seventy percent over the next
two decades and that's really linked to
everything from a greater number of
people living longer in the world to to
changes in lifestyle as developing
nations become richer and people have
much more luxurious loves lifestyles the
five most common sites of cancer
diagnosis in 2012 were lung prostate
colorectal stomach and liver cancer and
men and in women they shared a few of
those so colorectal and lung will share
it however cervical and breast cancer
are really the major causes of cancer in
women one-third of all cancer deaths are
really a result of behavioral and
dietary risk so this is why we see an
expansion of over seventy percent of
cancer cases and we need a lot of those
coming from emerging economies where
behavioral and dietary risk will rise
and over this time these include things
like a very high body mass index or BMI
which is also linked to obesity rise a
decline in fruit and vegetable intake as
well as in physical activity as people
become more prosperous and learn and of
course there is this strong effort
around the globe to curtail tobacco
usage but but these things still
contribute quite heavily to to cancers
that you see
interestingly and something quite
germane to the South African landscape
is that about twenty percent of of
cancers are caused by viral infections
and this really is quite prevalent in
low and middle income countries South
Africa is considered a middle-income
country and we have more than sixty
percent of the world's new cases of
cancer occurring in Africa Asia and
Central and South America so seventy
percent of the burden of cancer going
forward is going to be come from these
regions of the world and most of the
research efforts are really focused
outside these regions really focused in
North America and Europe predominantly
um one reason why viral infections 10
are a very important consideration is
because South Africa has the highest
burden of HIV in the world with over 5
million people who are HIV positive one
of the consequences of that is is that
South Africa also has a very high number
of hiv-related involve lymphomas more so
than than any other country so um this
combination of viral infection and
cancer is particularly the relevant in
South Africa um so specific to South
Africa the curation of epidemiological
data on cancer in South Africa so far
has been quite poor and that is also for
historical reasons but also because a
major focus of the Department of Health
and South Africa has been on the tree
predominant epidemics which has been HIV
and TB will be no 5 over 5 million
people HIV positive in South Africa and
seventy percent of those people testing
positive also for tuberculosis or
seventy percent of that five million are
co-infected the huge focus has been on
those individuals so the health system
has really been heavily burdened by this
infectious diseases that have really
made it difficult to to mount an
effective response to cancer however um
it's pretty clear that a lot of people
in South Africa are succumbing to cancer
and the number of cancer that is grossly
underreported as is the number of new
cases per year the majority of
individuals in South Africa and in
Africa have genetic backgrounds or
possess genetic variants of known and
unknown significance that have not been
previously associated with cancers so
this also makes it very difficult to be
able to for example do effective brca1
testing in women since the variants that
are identified in individuals and the
majority of individuals in South Africa
are really of variants that haven't been
seen in SE North America Europe in jeans
like brca1 and 2 one of the most
striking things that happens because of
this is background and sort of the lack
of epidemiological data on cancer in
South Africa is that we have very highly
divergent outcomes from cancer therapy
and that's broadly speaking in Africa
and and specific to South Africa as well
and those divergent outcomes will be
reflected in the next couple of slides
that i'm going to show you so here we
see the geographic distribution of
non-communicable diseases amongst which
cancer is one and it's quite striking
that you know the death rate from non
communicable diseases in Europe is by
far the lowest 400,000 individuals and
you see in Africa and parts of Asia is
highly elevated and this is the from
data from the wh 0 and and
sort of underlines the fact that the non
communicable disease burden is really
emerging health Skinner for for emerging
economies around the world if we were to
take the cancer portion of those non
communicable diseases what becomes
evident is that the data rates that are
for each individual / standardized
age-standardized areas are also quite
elevated in those three continents again
asia africa and and eight and South
America and for breast cancer
specifically what we find is that the
incidence of breast cancer is seems to
be much higher in the developed nations
forensically because they are mechanisms
of collecting epidemiological data
armload far more advanced more recent
data has shown that the actual incidents
in women of breast cancer is quite
similar for example between South
African United States so around ten
percent of women who will get first
cancer in the United States and a
similar percentage will become positive
for breast cancer during their lifetime
in South Africa so those statistics show
that the general incidence of breast
cancer in these two populations is
similar however it seems that the
genetic variants that we know are
associated with cancer between these two
countries or different continents are
quite divergent so the ability to test
prophylactically for brca1 and 2
variants that are driving cancers in
africa is something that is really
really underdeveloped so when we look at
very now looking at individual
statistics for different cancers that
occur in Africa again these these these
statistics are quite out of date and and
it shows you you know seven-year-old
statistics show you the velocity of data
that's collected on cancer in Africa
you can see here between males and
females that breast cancer for females
and cervical cancer are very high and
prostate and liver cancer figure very
very high in males in Africa and sort of
these are the primary reasons why we
have cancer in Africa in South Africa
skin cancer turns out to be the second
hi turns out to be one of the highest
rates of skin cancer in the world of any
pets just behind Australia which has the
number one incidence of skin cancer um
now they could be several reasons for
that including the fact that South
Africa has one of the highest levels of
solar exposure in the world so the
highest is in Chilean and the second
highest this is in South Africa if we're
going to look at mortality rates this is
worthy the story of Trantor in in Africa
becomes decidedly more more sad um if
you look on to the left of this graph
you see in North America um the green
bar represents the incidence of cancer
and the red bars for example all the way
of extreme left for North America
represents the mortality rate so if you
are a woman in North North America you
are the incidence of insolence ten
percent or ninety individuals per
100,000 and the mortality is around 15
to to ten percent now if you look at one
of those asterisks and say if you look
at the second asteroids which represents
southern Africa so southern Africa
includes South Africa Botswana
Mozambique Namibia Xena voice la hija de
Soto so extreme southern tip of Africa
um there is a complete conversion of
those statistics so you have our first
of all very under reported incidences as
we
mentioned before but the mortality rate
is extremely high and so it's you're
looking at perhaps over half of women
who have breast cancer in this part of
the world we will too high and and those
numbers are really shocking and they
this is likely the South African
government has really tried to catalyze
an investment in oncology and person
within precision medicine to be able to
reverse these sorts of trends so what is
precision medicine in oncology and
really what it is is it aims to identify
the genomic an epigenetic changes and
patterns and individuals that may
influence therapeutic outcomes and this
type of research can really broaden the
number of treatment options for patients
whose cancer is not responding to to
standard therapy um and one of the real
important technologies that's been able
to to bring about precision medicine is
genomic information and let us shape the
development and use of of some of the
newest cancer treatments but it's also
enabled the stratification of cancer
patients into appropriate drugs that
could be used to precisely treat
specific variants that are associated
with specific tumors and we'll get into
that little more deeply in this slide
when we see examples of precision
therapy arising some time ago book 10 12
years ago with lyric and lyric was is
cancer therapy those specifically
designed to inhibit an altered enzyme
that is related to chronic myelogenous
leukemia CML and and basically the
testing of the this is some
translocation that's associated with CML
and the fusion of two genes by a genetic
translocation would be a prerequisite
for for the prescription of Gleevec and
reebok was extremely effective in
inhibiting this ultra enzyme produced by
the fusion of these two genes and this
is resulted in a market reduction of
deaths from from CML another precision
medicine drug and this is again a sort
of a first generation precision medicine
drugs is Herceptin and Herceptin is a
drug that is only prescribed after
specific types of diagnosis and in this
case these diagnoses are related to
women whose breast cancer tumors are
hurtin positive on their surface and
again this has resulted in very positive
outcomes for women who test positive the
diagnostic for for these four or two
receptors and and led to a market
reduction in mortality of breast cancer
as we should show a couple of slides
before um so lung cancer patient tumors
can also be treated with precision
medicine approaches and these really
center around mutations that exists in
the EGF receptor and those respond
positively to 22 drives array santoor
seba and they specifically target that
mutation and again genomic information
is required to be able to stratify
individuals who have lung cancer for
their susceptibility to these two drugs
and also finally colon cancer sort of
falls into this first group of first
generate into this group of first
generation a precision medicine
therapies and here mutations in chaos
will get some benefit from the use of
these drugs um which are really with
some effect back to mix and relatives
here be tux
are two drugs that have been used for
kayla's mutations now this generation of
drugs really points to something quite
interesting which is called development
of what is generally thought of as gene
drug association so we have a gene and
we've identified specific genomic
regions and these lesions result in the
production of parent proteins which can
be directly treated with small molecules
in all of these cases which are which
are able to eliminate the activity of
these these apparent genes there's also
a couple of these like perception each
mortifying wanna call antibody but in
general this generation of drugs which
were associated with specific genetic
lesions are small molecule drugs um the
latest precision therapies are more
around trying to boost the immune system
to respond positively to cancer and a
whole class of these is a resilient us
cause a great deal of excitement in the
cancer therapy field and these are these
are termed checkpoint therapies
currently only one of these has been FDA
approved and these are since the PDA 10
ppl one targeting drugs and this drug is
traded under two names one from
bristol-myers squibb than the other one
from Merck which is key Trudeau and diva
and they essentially use humanized
antibodies which are targeting the pd-1
receptor which is displayed
predominantly on tumor cells and this
son this this receptor is targeted by by
the monoclonal antibodies and is then
able by targeting this receptor is able
to mask its presence to to the immune
system that allows the immune system to
that respond positively to go to the
tumor
so these drugs really function best
again when they are accompanied by a
companion diagnostic and actually this
pd-1 antibody therapies were one of the
first instances where a drug was also
approved with its companion diagnostic
that went along with them with them
being able to again individually target
patients for being for the use of this
specific Chancellor so um we essentially
now in precision medicine ecology are
dealing with the type of genomic
information that will really drive
research strategies and other strategies
that enable us to identify a given set
of genomic regions and I the real power
is to be able to identify the markers of
the disease to be able to stratify
patients but not only not then using say
umino therapy to selectively target
those markers and use those approaches
to become an integral part of precision
medicine and one of the key parts of
this is that since we are using genetics
to be able to come up with these markers
to be able to target individuals and
stratify individuals who have cancer and
use those markers as companion
diagnostics to be able to prescribe
therapy then our knowledge of genetic
variants becomes very important and it
and since genetic variants is highly
deterministic of our therapeutic
approach the population in which these
oncology drugs are developing
necessarily plays a critical role in
determining the jean-jacques
associations now that means that in
populations like that in sub-saharan
Africa where there's a high degree of
genetic variation in genetic diversity
that becomes important in the
development of oncology therapies and
more specifically in precision medicine
now since this part of the world has
some of the greatest amount of genetic
diversity you would think that it will
feature prominently in oncology drug
trials to be able to establish the
genetic variants and relate that genetic
variants to the adequate or correct drug
unfortunately um that isn't the case and
in fact the smallest cohort of
individuals come from Africa and that
are used and he's encouraging
therapeutic studies so there's really a
very high quality of information about
genetic variants and its relationship to
other situations so we know that in
looking at genome-wide snip data from
from over a hundred different
populations around the world and just
comparing their genes and the specific
geography we find that there is a very
very strong linkage between the genetic
diversity of the specific population and
their geography to put it another way
people who live in the same geography
tend to share the same variance and so
since people in say in Japan share a lot
of the same geography on an island their
genetic variants are going to be highly
shared that means that um certainly drug
regimes and it's the identification of
certain genetic variants that on linked
to specific therapeutic outcomes or
linked to specific uses own certain
drugs is also very likely to be
something that has to be developed
within the locale of these geographies
therefore it means that we sort of gene
drug association studies which are
reading the key to precision medicine
will need to be by default conducted in
these local geographies and take into
account the landscape of genetic
variation and and this is really what
germinates me strong interest in
precision medicine as it relates to
oncology in South Africa because even
those specific therapies do exist the
real challenge for using these
pre-existing therapies that we know have
are targeting specific genetic lesions
is to understand whether variants that
exist in southern Africa are can which
are quite different from those that
exist in individuals in Europe and North
America those variants in Africa are
they linked are they linkable to
specific drugs that are currently used
outside Africa for this type of oncology
and that's a very important
consideration because it's not that the
drugs will not work it's trying to
understand the appropriate variants to
stratify individuals to find individuals
who need respond positively to those
drugs so the most frequent cancer among
women as we this is this really breast
cancer and and the rate of breast cancer
again our statistics are not that good
in South Africa moment but they are that
incidence is seen to be about 27 and
100,000 with mortality rate as recently
as 2013 over 3,000 deaths mortality from
breast cancer accounts for of sixteen
percent of all cancer deaths in women
and and because of the factors that I
mentioned before women usually present
at quite a late stage of the disease so
um this this breast cancer is something
that is one of our pilot cases that we
are pursuing in our precision letters
initiative here in South Africa and one
of the reasons is also because there's a
very low level of breast cancer
awareness in general and since all
diseases are really have a molecular
etiology with significant differences
from individual to individual one of the
key parts of just doing basic breast
cancer screening which is very standard
in Europe and North America is really
that's done on genetic variants and
unfortunately this type of screening
need South Africa even if it's done
there's there's not much epidemiological
awareness of what variants could be
linked to brca1 that are predominantly
African population so um so this
confluence of issues really means that
they're important challenges that need
to be overcome in in bringing this sort
of precision medicine to oncology and
and that's really one of the first
things we aim to do here so one of them
is to link the African genomic diversity
and that's really provided by different
levels of probing and here we call these
types of probes um genomic and
epigenetic approaches combined with
antibodies stratification approaches and
so what we mean specifically there it's
being able to just use molecular
techniques for example to determine
triple negative status of breast cancer
tumors and to be able to couple that
with the ability of doing
next-generation sequencing of tumors and
in fact even being able to do single
cell sequencing of tumors and then if
necessary combining that with at the
genetic approaches so the chips week and
other types of epigenetic analyses of
these tumors and that would end
was to develop a better understanding of
the genetic diversity associated two
months and also allow us to develop very
targeted therapeutic regimens a second
aim of this stage of the project is
really to be able to create something
that exists quite uniquely in Europe
which was established by Hans cleavers
which is to create a living by oh bond
and the concept of a living by bike is a
term that was coined by Hans Gruber's
and it's the ability to grow to more
organized so to kind of take a harvested
tumor and and cultivate that tumor ex
vivo into organoids and by being able to
do that it creates a resource that would
be available to scientists oncologists
and including pharma and biotech
companies that can also use that
resource to screen for new drugs for
scientists to understand me etiology and
mechanisms associated with the tumor and
to be able to interact with oncologist
to understand how to develop which is
new medicine or guided therapeutic
approaches to those tumors so um the
idea is to use the data generated from
this initiative to introduce precision
medicine much broader scale and to come
up with highly specialized treatments
that are adjusted to companion
diagnostics and this is this is we need
to reverse this is horrific trend where
in general in Europe and North America
seventy percent of people will survive
cancer and in in Africa seventy percent
of people will were unfortunately type
of cancer if they get it so
being able to reverse this trend means
the ability to rapidly understand and
diagnose cancer very early understand
the variants that are linked to the most
positive therapeutic outcomes and those
variants that is forming most
appropriately to precision drugs that
can be used and give patients a very
high probability of success another
initiative we have here is to be able to
properly then curate large-scale
databases on this sort of information
that extend information on South African
cancer genomics and they're hidden
outcomes um We strongly believe that
driving this initiative in South Africa
will have major implications for the
treatment of cancer in other parts of
the world in and other parts of Africa
sorry and also in other parts of the
world so kind of summarizing our
approach in and to the barring a little
bit from from what's being done at the
University of each session where Hans
cleavers has established living by banks
is really first of all be routinely able
to take normal and to a tissue from a
patient and take this tissue and be able
to sequence it using next-generation
approaches and then being able to
cultivate the normal and tumor tissues
an organized and to be able to buy a bag
and store that the idea as mentioned
earlier and this were kind of in the
pilot phase of this is to be maintained
ex vivo cultivation of these two more
organized and Bank them over the long
term secondly we'd like to establish the
genomic and at the genetic analysis
associated with a subset of these tumors
that will inform of course research
purposes but also that will enable us in
being able to do stratification by Nina
logical phenotyping so using
for example article is 2 for 2 receptors
and being able to to score for triple
negative status and breast cancer and
and finally to identify genetic variants
of tumors that are linked to specific
outcomes a third reason is um we we are
now establishing a whole drug array
which I will go into where we have all
the first line fda-approved drugs for
oncology and you would like to expose
these two more ergonomic to these drugs
to at least have some sort of
inflammation ex vivo of the
susceptibility of the tumor to specific
drug regimens to assist oncologist being
able to make informed choices around
therapy so so in one part of this we
take the genomic information and some
check that too specific pharmacogenomic
analyses and work with a team of violet
itions here who enable us to be able to
use existing databases and see whether
or not to their pipelines we can infer
things even with variants of unknown
significance whether we can actually
elevate those variants two variants that
have are likely targets or indicators of
specific therapeutic options the second
is to really expand to yourselves in in
vitro culture by organoid approaches and
obviously continues to evaluate the
expansion of those organoids to
sequencing records and maintain those in
the databases but in a second part of
this you are really wanting to check
drug sensitivity and something that's
not done at all in South Africa um and
that allows us to be able to interrogate
accessible drugs for their ability to
to reduce tumor growth and and to
continuously kappa resource available
for either new drugs or the use of RNAi
or crisper interference technologies
that are able to target specific genes
that could be related to expansion of
those tumors so on one side this would
help us to advise the college's on
clinical approaches and clinical
treatment and on the other side of the
cases where we may have much more
advanced they'd face kiss cancer um we
would use more novel approaches such as
a rage my head screening or even late
stage facing me drugs to be able to
understand if there are new and novel
therapies out there that could be could
be available to to to treat these tumors
so um overall this is the workload that
we are are currently developing here and
we've been working quite extensively
with some leading institutes in terms
and research including the MD Anderson
Cancer Research Center in in Texas so um
another private partnership that we tell
we have been working quite a Bigfoot is
a partnership that was a a small company
that came from the CSer and that has
been able to develop arraign
technologies that allow us to rapidly
interrogate through RNA interference
meaning and also through the use of
small-molecule treatment or small
molecule fda-approved drugs that will be
printed on these sorts of a race if that
allows us to actually use drug array or
Han interference or even crisper i late
christopher libraries to be able to
rapidly test for the susceptibility of
tumor
to specific jars or or genetic
interventions so a lot of these markers
of disease that we identify when the
first stage of this will be used to
develop what we would call knowledgeable
and very marker specific diagnostics and
and we have here the at the Medical
School large proteomics and metabolomics
platforms of your establishing that can
confirm the validity of these markers
and help to identify them the
therapeutic side is really a secondary
side to this initiative but our idea is
we need to be able to identify specific
substrates and key interacting
components signal transaction pathways
and generate good pre clinical
validation of these products we also
have just developed a humanized mask
facility here at the University that
allows us to do and Beaver Island more
studies using transgenic and and human
eyes nice and finally um you know the
thing that's really attracted a lot of
attention as I said earlier is the
promise of animal therapy and one of the
things that we are trying to do here
it's really to find ways which everybody
in the field is trying to do to be able
to stratify patients into two groups
that would have positive outcomes in
tuen current in the therapeutic
approaches so um you know these
immunotherapy approaches really have
four categories and one of them is
adopted some are antibody-based like
whittling that i mentioned with pd-1
therapy cancer vaccine therapy like the
type of spouse by shriver and courses
allergen-specific immunotherapies all of
these are very very cutting edge
technologies
we have focused a lot of antibody-based
immunotherapies in our collaborations
and and we're really looking to expand
our knowledge outside means to two
different areas in the immunotherapy
space so um just in this last slide I
really want to sort of summarize how we
see the process of implementing
precision medicine in the space in South
Africa and and the reason that we're
kind of very very positive apophysis is
print primarily because we want to
concentrate the knowledge that we have
in this area we want to be able to get
to a state where we have very well
making our characterized tumors which is
really the state of the art of oncology
around the world we'd like to have very
good correlates of intercellular extra
set of targets of a specific to evolve
cancer we'd like to correlate sowwie
surface receptor profile to genomics so
another words label to know more
specific genetic region is leading to a
change in cell surface receptors we'd
like to know that epigenetic status is
leading to a change in say metastatic
slivers we'd like to know that we can
validate these markers at the surface
and we went to correlate most important
ligaments for the precision medicine
drug sensitivity to the molecular
characteristics of the tumor and you
believe that this last one being able to
do this we need change our auto ratio of
seventy percent mortality in the Africa
221 that's nearing for approaching what
you'd find in Europe and the United
States which is seventy percent survival
from cancer so with that I just want to
acknowledge my a co-principal
investigator on this he was a professor
stefan bart is a south african
researcher can survive
LG was also here at the University of
Cape Town members of his lab nah man and
we received a large support for this
effort from the Medical Research Council
of South Africa the Department of
Science and Technology the council for
scientific and industrial research and
University of Cape Town Faculty of
Medicine thanks a lot for your attention
Thank You community Musa thank you so
much for that fascinating presentation
on bringing precision medicine in
oncology to South Africa I've got a few
questions for you and since I'll take
the liberty of asking know since you
don't have the ability of a live Q&A for
this particular session so let's begin
by talking about some of the other
topics that will be presented here at
the inaugural precision medicine virtual
event including a discussion of the
precision medicine initiative and I
think also relevant in your presentation
the even more recently announced cancer
moonshot acela calls and we had a lot of
these big sky answer initiatives it
seems at the moment and people are
generally excited about them although
there are often concerns raised about
the diversion of funds to these big
science initiatives that may take away
from smaller independent investigators I
wonder Musa do you find these the PMI
and the cancer moon but do these have
immediate implications and benefits for
the kinds of research and clinical
progress you're trying to implement in
South Africa or is there still a bit of
a disconnect in other ways that you
would like to get more attention from
investigators in state in North America
to consider your needs as the a as these
Graham's develop thanks Kevin um really
interesting question you asked there and
I I find that the state of cancer
therapy in the state of cancer research
are really on these very obvious from
from some of the slides I served in this
talk are really on two completely
different tracks between Africa and say
in North America and Europe and and so
in terms of the cancer moonshot I think
we've seen some really exciting
developments in cancer research from
laboratory for example of james allison
and in others that have shown really
amazing feats reversals and emissions
that can occur even in late stage
cancers and the continued ensured i
think in serve as much as it's a big
science project that sucks up a lot of
money i think is going to extend these
quite greatly what I also see is that um
the the National Cancer Institute which
is an institute of the NIH has taken a
very deep interest in cancer in Africa
um most of the focus of of the NIH
funding to South Africa overwhelming
focus has been in HIV MTV the National
Cancer Institute recently launched an
initiative which our university is
hoping to participate in for a to kind
of elevate the level of cancer knowledge
and cancer therapy by developing cancer
research centers in Africa so um what I
do my answer to your question of
attention is that it seems that the ease
attention focused as well in Africa
maybe not as much money in
not as much visibility but there
definitely is attention that's been
focused from the National Cancer
Institute um I think also what has
happened is that they are a lot of
initiatives that are homegrown like the
one that we have been graciously
supported by the South African
government to to sort of kickstart much
more interest in this area but they are
encouraging us to work very closely with
our colleagues in North America and
Europe e basic research and as well as
in the pharmaceutical industry so I
think what we what's emerging here is is
definitely some deep interest that's
coming from from North America and
Europe and we may not be at the level of
doing tailem based car therapy but we
certainly are on the radar for immuno
other types of immunotherapy like TV one
day
thanks Musa and I think I just time for
one final question perhaps give you a
chance to elaborate a little bit on your
collaboration with hands cleavers who
you mentioned a couple of times and I
may have missed it but what what are
some of the numbers that you are hoping
to aim for in coming years of regard to
developing this South African oncology
biobank and if we could look forward in
three to five years what how do you hope
that that resource will be assisting in
either personalized or precision
medicine an excellent so um I'm sorry if
I said we are collaborating with Hans
cleavers we actually are inspired by the
fact that they develop a sort of a fire
bank we are working with other people at
the Institute that he heads up and our
real goal is to be able to acquire the
same sort of proficiency in developing
his living by banks as they've been able
to do at me at the entity that he had I
think one of the key things that we'd
like to achieve here he's done is the
routine technical proficiency to develop
the source of living violence so looking
out from five years one of the how as
you said um be the initiative josh has
been able to think at last come get over
16 or 17 different organized known that
they had their living by a bank and then
grass blade installations as
I think we probably people around that
same numbers I think where we would
differ from what's happening in that
Institute is that um our goal is really
to be able to do a pilot study that will
then be able to show that this was a
very good working model that could be
rolled out to other parts of South
Africa so what I would like to see
really five years from now less around
the living violence because as I as I
mentioned having that you know fixed set
of them available that's quite
representative of the variance and
recently struck raphy would be would be
not but really what I'd like to see is
in the process of first of all
stratification and announces to be
vastly improved in other words I'd
really like to see that precision
medicine throughout South Africa becomes
routine in identifying what types of
cancer a person has its genetic etiology
what the best therapeutic options are
and all of these to be done with the
latest molecular information and a
combination of obviously large databases
that we open will be able to populate
over the next few years about the level
of genetic variants that exist for
different cancers in South Africa so the
real goal is identification of molecular
diversity of genetic diversity you know
stratification or as many people as
possible who have cancer in South Africa
for that to be able to inform how
therapy is prescribed routinely and for
that to improve outcomes so that you
don't have a seven and ten people
succumbing to transient South Africa and
to show those trends dropping
significantly five years that would that
would be a positive outcome for four
project for me I'm sure for Stefan as
well well mr. thank you very much we
will leave it there I've been a
fascinating 45 or 50 minutes hearing
about advances in precision medicine in
South Africa so that was so malanga from
the University of Cape Town I hope you
enjoyed that presentation continuing
education credits so available for those
who wish and this presentation will be
archived like the entire suppose in
today for another six months so you able
to share links to that presentation and
the other 11 so tooks throughout the day
with your colleagues and people who are
unable to join John Dave the actual
broadcast I think that's all then for me
for Kevin Davis and senior media group
the exhibit show floor is at Brooklyn
please go and support people who helped
make this symposium possible and we hope
you will stay tuned for the next
presentation to hear at the inaugural
precision medicine virtual event cell
behalf of the senior media group and lab
brutes I'm Kevin Davis thanks for
watching and stay tuned for our next
presentation at the top of the hour bye
bye for now